I'm sad there's women's chess I don't
think there should be women's chess I
think the idea is that we're getting to
this point in society slowly and it's
wonderful to see the champions in China
and India I mean it's funny that
non-western societies are producing the
best women chess players but I would
hope that we're working on the
underpinning problems that lead to this
kind of huge confidence issue perhaps
that psyches women out and I yeah I do I
think that you know the answer is not to
say oh poor women are so tremulous but
to just you know be cracked down on Men
Behaving Badly and in mixed competitions
and yeah keep it keep it open to anyone
trans women women men trans men and just
you know chess chess is not people call
it a sport I've never understood that